my jury that I have on now might be
worth like half of me not easy but I
didn't get a check for a million dollars
and go spend a half a million dollars on
drew all the time I spent 60,000 when I
had a meeting nobody's just gonna blow
your money on the jury to keep up cuz it
could like lose value you can lose it
take your time spend it wisely
[Music]
when when we should go a little big
right now you're on the rough checking
out my jury
there's a lot of people out there were a
good good you know Floyd Mayweather
little coarse Gucci Mane one who wants
we got a lot of jury I'm saying see he
he he more one of those people who kind
of like inspire me on my journey like
that Lana seeing all the people big
change
watches Rolex date just this watch was
actually gifted to me my first one is
give to me like no diamonds well
actually this watch was more like
sentimental you know I'm saying so
instead of just buying a new Weiss and
keeping this and I just like add it on
in this watch I actually paid more for
this watch then you were regular pay for
one because I I built the watch tonight
from scratch this watch sir ap watch
loose loose and ap my honey cone said
they got paid like maybe fifty five
thousand sixty times watch a minute ago
I would watch this for more of a fashion
I were two watches a lot and I neither
one of them never had the correct time I
got on two watches us they're coming
late
look Cuban link bracelet I hardly ever
take it off I actually had this gold at
first I got him doing white coming to be
two wars weekend so I just
[Music]
our people have a star ring I'm saying
initially like being like future and
maybe I'm still having first I'm saying
like a lot of people got none but
thinking they started actually we're
both for them at any time time due to
the fact I wore two watches most of the
time I just try to kind of balance it
out like that specially nice fresh it
ring um I just got both of these rooms
recently like I haven't had an even one
for over like last month I had maybe
seven rings but I lost all of them like
I don't even know just look down like
what my ring just like one week I lost
two days we got lost on this I lost
three I just so I just bought these two
that I have I really miss you man yeah I
kind of like rings when I'm performing
because I kind of hold it might mean
kind of like see the ring but I can
little baby of course this is me I'm
sitting on ice and I got the name little
baby from like hanging around olden dude
I was maybe like 12 13 hang around dudes
2025 I was actually a baby just being a
younger kid around I just came up with a
little baby a little baby I ran with it
and most of these pennies down like
maybe like 15 point of change 15 partner
diamond turns it cost me like 15,000
foot make connecting yourself without
dependent maybe penny I think I paid
maybe like twenty five thousand right
and this one is on folks I'm saying buy
in Atlanta it's divided into zones and
where I grew up at and then they were
hooded I come from its own folk but it's
like sentimental to me to let people
know where I come from I'm saying not
just Atlanta let it put like wearing
Ellen I'm almost 100% sure that the
zones came from like police like that's
how they district off the air this one
right here it's faux Peter that's like
my my label I'm saying my brand I stand
on this four-piece band for for parties
for that's my movement for packaged food
and saying they literally mean you have
all four your pockets full but it's just
a fact of just being having a lot of
money
first I had a chain was just the number
fold with the P&L my name is anybody
like I've been just sitting in the house
one day and I just was trying and then I
just Julie like this and sent it to the
jeweler he sent me back a farm matter
whatever and I've been going with it
when my logo I haven't got a copyrighted
since Danny is my LLC solid foundation
he's not management company call a solid
foundation
Coach K and P from Q see a lot of people
thought I was like Sonic you see but
he's my managers they like Sonic
foundation I don't know what this mean
all of us got low again got these these
heart
[Music]
just a big down once then picked up its
the QC Chang I'm saying big Cuban link
Rose going white will be now this chain
is so heavy I'm not for sure exactly how
much it weighs but I wear it a lot when
I go out as soon as I leave I take it
off this piece because like oh I heard
you down this is the Cuban link may be
costing me like eighty thousand that
won't move this percent milk my foot PMI
logo my breath I need me a big dog chain
like that so I want that to be the
biggest thing they see because that's
what I'm working on fires right now
[Music]
these are smaller than a lot but more
valuable than like these I have this
probably like my third pair earrings
this year because I might go to sleep on
the plane or anywhere and then losers
may be so hard to find I had asked my
mom so I get my ears pierced and I was
like 10 or 11 and she told me no and I
put a piece of ice out to freeze on my
ears
they're my irrigate no they're my inking
on get the alcohol get alcohol and just
get it earring and actually like this
pitch my own I used to imagine earring
these same kind of earrings for about
4-5 hours now I've spent forty fifty
thousand and okay